he stated my name is Kevin Langley I
work with human made at human made we
create WordPress applications for
enterprise clients so one thing I wanted
to say just from the start this is a
very long talk and there probably will
not be any time for questions so if you
have any questions that come up get with
me afterwards and we can go over
anything first we're gonna go over a
brief history of JavaScript so in May of
1995 JavaScript was originally developed
under the name of mocha it was released
in September of 95 under the name of
live script from there it was renamed a
javascript in December and that was with
the release of Netscape Navigator 2.0
and 96 Netscape submitted JavaScript to
the ECMA international for
Standardization and in 97 this resulted
in a new language standard known as
ECMAScript ECMAScript is a standard and
JavaScript is the most popular
implementation of that standard and also
builds on top of it other other
languages that also build on that
standard is ActionScript and jscript but
as you can tell javascript is the most
popular we don't have AJ script learn
jscript deeply course yes is short for
ECMAScript every time you see es
followed by a number it's referencing an
edition of the ecmascript so yes one in
97 yes - and 98 yes 3 and 99 yes 4 was
actually abandoned then we finally got
es 5 and this is what everyone is
probably familiar with this is what we
had for years and years came out in
December of 2009 and we didn't have any
any changes to JavaScript until June
2015 when we finally got es6 es 7 came
in 2016 and es 8 in 2017 now you're
probably wondering why isn't this course
called es 8 the reason being es6 was
really where we got the majority of our
changes yes seven es eight there was
only a handful of changes that got added
to JavaScript where as es6 was the
largest change that we have seen in the
language pretty much ever since its
release and es next is a term for
dynamic references to the
next version of ecmascript coming out so
the tc39 committee is responsible for
evolving ecmascript programming they
they go through stages for every single
one of their features that they want to
implement into javascript it starts with
the stage 0 strawman then the proposal
then the draft and then the candidate
without the tc39 we wouldn't be here
today they're the ones that have really
pioneered javascript to bring it to
where it is as modern as it is today and
as big as it is because of the the
changes that they continue to push out
in the language so the first thing we're
gonna jump into is es6 modules so
modules allow you to load your code
asynchronously and it provides a layer
of abstraction to your code there's two
ways to export from a module you can
have multiple name modules and you can
have single default exports so here's
some examples of these this is a
multiple named export so let's say we
have a function called square
it's just accepting a single value and
we're gonna go ahead and square that
value we have another function called
add again we're just adding those values
now if we export those functions from
our bath Liv Jas and then in our new
JavaScript file we want to use those how
would we use those normally we would
just add those we would somehow include
this script now with es6 we can simply
import it and this is probably familiar
if you're if you've ever used common Jas
before es6 became big they kind of
implemented the same exact syntax for
importing modules so as you can see
we're just importing Square and add from
math Lib and then we're can console.log
our square 9 and our ad 4 and 3 and it
works perfectly for us another way to do
it is single default exports so with
this you're just you're to exporting a
single function and then we can import
that function and run it very simple so
yes 6 tools there are a ton of tools out
there mainly transpilers such as babel
there are bundlers such as
pack and there are also systems that
deviate from that that allow you to use
a number of different things so babble
is one of the JavaScript transpilers
that allows you to convert your
JavaScript from es6 into es5 code and
what this does is it allows it to run in
any browser even even older browsers it
gives us the ability to use all the
syntactic all the syntactical sugar that
es6 provides us while still having the
fall backs as I said web pack is a
bundler and what it does is it
recursively builds a dependency graph
for your application and then
selectively includes those areas
depending on where you are in the front
end of your application next we're gonna
jump into variable scoping so everyone's
probably familiar with var you would
initialize a variable here set it to
equal to bar and console.log it and you
get it now VARs function scope now what
that means is that if I have a function
it's going to not leak out of that
function but if I have a block it can
leak out of the block blocks are
specifically the curly brackets that you
see now sometimes that that comes after
an if statement sometimes it comes for a
loop but it's not necessary a block can
literally be drawn out at any point if
you just create curly brackets now the
two new ones that we have are let and
const and these are block scope now as I
said blocks are specifically the curly
brackets themselves so if right here we
have this block and then we create two
variables let or const and we try to
console.log those we're going to get
reference errors because we're outside
of the block that those were actually
referenced in and that really allows us
to keep our code encapsulated where we
want it to be and not leak where it
needs where it shouldn't be leaking
here's an example of blocks so as you
can see we don't have an if statement
here we don't have a for loop we don't
have anything it's just we're starting a
new block level each time now we start
the first one then the second and the
third and if we try to access the third
variable outside of the third scale
we're gonna get a reference error and
the same thing that second and third and
that's what let but it's exactly the
same with Const now you're probably
wondering what's the difference between
letting Const so conce variables can
only be assigned once but they are not
immutable and that's a very common
misconception in es6 you can change the
properties of a Const variable you can
also if you actually want to change or
if you want to freeze the object to
where you cannot change any properties
you can use object freeze and if you
want to just be able to stop someone
from changing the structure of an object
that's where object seal comes in handy
but one thing to keep in mind as I said
it can only be instantiated once but it
is not immutable variable hoisting so
this is this is where this kind of gets
hairy hoisting is a JavaScript mechanism
where variables and functions get pulled
up to the top of their scope before code
execution that means that you can do
this with functions and VARs I can run
this function before it actually gets to
fine because as it's doing that in
runtime that function is going to be
brought up to the top before it even
calls it same thing over here
what actually happens with VARs is right
here if we do a console log foo bar
we're gonna get undefined and that's
because when you instantiate a variable
with var what it's actually doing is its
hoisting it up to the top and it's
setting its value and it's type equal to
undefined and then finally when it when
it gets down to the assignment that's
when it's actually assigning it but in
es6 you can't do that with classes you
can't do that with let variables and you
can't do that with const they are
hoisted but they're not initialized yet
and unlike FAR's and functions so if we
were to try to run this we'd get a type
error for our class because it has not
been created yet we get an error says a
foo is used before it was defined and
that's because that's exactly what
happens and it's the same thing with a
const variable as well so that's
something that you want to look out for
when you're using es6 another thing in
ESX is the
temporal deadzone in blocks so this is
our block just an if-statement and this
is where the temporal dead zone starts
so if we create a a function here or a
Const variable equal to a function and
we're console logging thing now where
does thing come from we don't have it
yet that isn't a problem until you try
to run that but if I actually set thing
then our tdz ends we're no longer in the
temporal dead zone and now if we call it
we're not going to get a reference error
but what should I use there's var
there's consulars let when should I use
these things what are their purposes so
the only difference between constant let
is that consummates the contract that no
rebinding will happen to the variable I
can create a let variable and then
reassign it as many times as I want if I
create a constable I cannot reassign it
I can only change properties on that
variable so there's two thoughts two
trains of thought when using when to use
these types of things
mattias binding his he's a va8 engineer
at Google he suggests to use const by
default only use let if rebinding is
needed and he personally thinks that VAR
shouldn't be used in the s 2015 and that
that's my personal belief as well this
is still a very opinionated thing that
everybody has their own opinions and
that's absolutely fine kyle simpson the
founder at getify he says that you
should use var for top-level variables
use let for localized variables in
smaller scope and you should refactor
let to Const only after some code has
been written and you're reasonably sure
that there isn't any variable
reassignment going to be happening
either one of these are totally valid
positions and you know as we get further
into the the ECMA standard and as it
gets further solidified in later years
this will probably be more concrete but
as right now it's kind of up to you on
how you want to treat that so we're
going to talk about intervals and
looping when you use var you actually
leak a global variable to the parent
scope because as I said var is function
scoped it's not going to be blocks ago
so as we're looping through we have our
VAR I equals 0 as long as I is less than
10 increase I and we're gonna do a set
timeout here and what do you think is
actually gonna happen here we're console
logging within our set timeout we're
console logging I we're gonna get the
number 10 is 10 times why is that that's
not what we wanted it's because what
happens is by the time this set timeout
runs and again this is just an example
imagine this is an ajax request or other
some other long-running process here by
the time it actually runs this
console.log after the 1 second i is
always 10 so if this isn't helpful at
all for anybody now if we use let in a
for in a for loop it allows us to have
the variable scope to that block so here
we have let it's exactly the same code
we just changed far to let and what's
that gonna give us exactly what we want
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 vs 6 also gives us
new way to loop over intervals so what
is an iterable an iterable is anything
that you can loop over it's an array its
arguments its node 'less now there are
certain ways to iterate over those
objects compared to others but what this
gives us is the availability to do four
of the iterable so we have this this
constant variable iterable it's 10 20
and 30 and if we do for each constable
and we a constant and we console.log it
we get 10 20 30 now this is also handy
when you want to loop over something
like a query selector so we go ahead and
we do a for your selector we get our
node list and we want to loop over that
now you can't just loop over that
normally but an es6 with the for of loop
you absolutely can because it's an it's
it's an array ish type is what a node
list is very similar to arguments in a
javascript function
and you can also loop over strings
because strings are again iterable as
well so we loop over foo and it gives us
each letter individually the next thing
we're going to talk about is arrow
functions and if you've ever worked
CoffeeScript or I believe I believe
typescript does some similar stuff this
might look similar they they based a lot
of the functionalities of es6 based on
other languages that we're trying to
take JavaScript further already so here
we have a traditional function
expression add numbers and that's going
to take in num1 and num2 and that's just
going to add the two and return them now
what arrow functions give us is a more
concise function expression so as you
can see here we removed the function
keyword and we just do an arrow start
the block close the block looks very
similar but arrow functions give us more
than that too they also have implicit
returns so what is an implicit return
this right here is an explicit return
we're specifically saying we're
returning this value plus this value now
with the implicit return this minimizes
it by two other you know we're removing
two lines off this function num1 plus
num2 and that already knows that as
we're finishing the arrow function like
this it is an implicit return it knows
that that's what we're returning there's
a few more examples of arrow functions
you can do things like I have no I have
no arguments in my arrow function BAM
just a open close parenthesis arrow
implicit return if you have a single
argument you don't need to wrap it
inside of a parenthesis you can just
have the single argument listed and if
you have multiple you go ahead and you
throw it into parenthesis and now
another thing that arrow functions give
us is it makes it to where you don't
have to do any of this bind or this or
that equals this or self equals this so
it picks up this value from its
surrounding so take this this example
here we have a function person object
and this page equals zero set interval
and we're increasing
the age but right here this refers to
the window and that's not at all what we
want we want it to refer to the person
object so back in the day we might do
this bar that equals this and now we can
do that plus age plus plus and yeah that
works but it's not ideal so let's dive
in a little bit further we use an arrow
function and it properly this was
properly referring to the person object
now and we don't have to use any find
that or self when should I use arrow
function so it's not always appropriate
take this example for instance we have a
button that's equal to our your selector
of my button and then we're adding an
event listener for click and then we're
doing this dot classless toggle and that
looks right but this is referring to the
window because we're not within a scope
that tells us what our this is so if
it's gonna pick up into this based on
its surroundings there's nothing that
tells it what it should be so of course
it's going to be the window so fern for
an example like this it's not even
proper to use a an arrow function you
would just use a regular function here
that way the value of this would be your
button that you're that you're calling
your event on another awesome thing that
es6 gives us is default arguments in
JavaScript so here we have a basic
function we're gonna calculate the total
based on subtotal the tax rate and the
shipping charge so we're just returning
subtotal plus shipping plus subtotal
time tax and if we go ahead and we run
that we get our value but let's go ahead
and have some defaults into the argument
so those are the old way of doing it if
tax equals equals equals undefined set
the tax if shipping is undefined go and
set the shipping but we just we just
added like five six lines to our
variable or to our function here and
that's not ideal so this is a little bit
better this is still without using the S
six we're just cleaning it up a little
bit still better but not
the best now here we go it is now we're
back to the same line length that we had
when we had no defaults but we're have
our defaults in there so we know they're
always going to be set even if they're
not passed in but what if I only want to
pass in the first and third arguments
can I just do this nope syntax error
what you're gonna want to pass in is
undefined so if you pass in undefined as
tax or as shipping it's going to know
okay this is undefined so set it to the
default and same thing if you were to
just leave off the last one if if you
wanted to actually just leave it off
then that's fine too if you only passed
in 100 the other two would straight
default but if you needed to have it to
where it's split in a middle argument
somewhere needed to be empty that's
exactly how to define that the next
topic we're going to be discussing is D
structuring so here we have a person
object Kevin Langley my location is
Beverly Hills Florida and let's create
some variables from that object so let's
create a first and that's equal to
person up first
it's create a last variable that's equal
to person that last but with
destructuring we can actually do this
put it in curly brackets and just say
first comma last
equals person and that's gonna pull the
variables or the the properties out of
this object that are equal to first and
equal to last and set them to those
variables now we can use those anywhere
in our application that comes in handy a
lot and it also comes in handy with
nested properties as well and you can
also rename the variables of a
destructured object so you're not stuck
just with the the keys that the object
gives you say I want my variable to
actually be fname and lname
but they're going to come from first and
from last inside of our object and same
thing here instead of city a city is the
key but we're going to be naming it
location city in our application and
location state and those would be the
variable names that we would use
throughout the rest of our application
as we go on there so what if I try to do
structure property that doesn't
yet so here an example would be you have
a settings object and we have a color
property and a height property and we're
trying to be structure that into the
width height and a color but we don't
have any width property here so what
would that do that's going to give us an
undefined and that's absolutely fine if
that's what you're looking for but
another thing you could do very similar
to the default arguments in a function
you can actually set defaults and your
destructuring even and this cleans up
your code so much so now if we were to
do structure this it would automatically
be equal to two because it knows that we
haven't passed one in inside of our
settings variable and as you can see our
values have overwritten the defaults
here for height and for color you can do
structure arrays as well and this is
nice when you get data coming back from
either an API or some other form where
it's it's an array and it's not it's not
really in a clean way where you have the
keys and you know what they're linking
up to there but if you know that it's in
a specific order you could go ahead and
do structure it first last website
equals details and that's going to pull
in those values exactly like what we
would think
so the next topic is we're gonna have to
dive a little bit in because spread and
rest are amazing and awesome as hell but
can get a little confusing so before es6
we would run we were going to run apply
to pass in an array of arguments so
let's say we had a function called do
something and it takes it in XY and z
and we're just console logging we have a
variable here args and that's zero one
two and in order to call this function
and pass in these arguments as single
arguments here and not as the array we
have normally we'd run apply but then we
have to specify we want null for our
this value and our arms are gonna split
up there and that works but another way
to do it is with the spread operator so
what the spread operator does is almost
almost exactly like what it sounds like
it's gonna take this argument this array
here and it's gonna spread it out to
where do something is actually 1 2 or 0
1 & 2 and this is very useful in number
of ways
so you can use a spread operator to
combine arrays let's say I had two
different arrays and it has 1 2 & 3 & 4
& 5 in our array 1 we could push the
spread of array 2 and what that does is
it adds all the items from array 2 to
our array and we can also do the same
thing we can unshifted and add those
items to the beginning of the array or
we can also combine arrays at any point
that we want to so let's say our array 1
is actually equal to 2 & 3 and array 2
is equal to 1 and then we put in the
array 1 we spread that out that is what
our values gonna be 1 2 3 4 5
it specifically spreads out those values
at any point that you want to and that
allows you to just have a ton of control
over your arrays if you need to insert
things at a certain area after something
else
you just have full control over whatever
you want to do with those without having
to loop over them check values here and
there
you can also use the sprayer operator
create a copy of an array so we know
that if we just took array 1 equals
array 2 it's gonna it's gonna keep a
reference to that it's not just creating
new array there so what we can do is we
can actually spread array 1 into a new
array and now if we push for onto our
array 2 we have two different arrays
they're not keeping a reference to each
other and that you're not going to run
into problems where you have where you
need a copy and you need to adjust that
one copy but keep the the reference the
original you can also use the spreader
operator with destructuring which is
amazing so here's an example we have
players Kevin Bobby Nichole Naomi Jim
Sheree so let's say we want to get that
this is the order that they placed and
you know well it was a most of the time
you care mostly about the first second
and third place you can place those
players and the rest of them we're just
gonna go into unplaced so what that does
is that's going to make Kevin first
Bobby's second Nichole third and
unplaced is going to be all the rest of
them there and you can use it with
destructuring objects as well so here we
have X Y and then just put the rest into
Z and as you can see we have 1 4 X 2 for
y and z is a 2 a 3 and B is 4 and you
can use the spread operator to expand a
node list so if I just tried to loop
over document query selector all it's
not gonna let us loop over it because
it's not a it's not an array it isn't it
is an array like item but it is not an
actual array but if we throw that into
it into a spread or add a spreader
operator and throw it into an array here
now I didn't have an example here
because I don't have any divs on the
page but it would list all of your divs
so the other operator here is the rest
operator and the rest operator is almost
the exact opposite
the rest operator allows us to more
handle iver more easily handle a
variable number of function parameters
so let's say we have a function do math
and we're taking it an operator and
we're taking in a set of numbers as you
can see it can be any length we could
add 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 all the way up
whatever numbers that we want to and no
matter what this second variable will
always be an array of all the other
variables passed into this function and
that makes it really easy because if you
have a number of arguments but you don't
know exactly how many you're gonna need
or you don't know ahead of time you
don't want to plan that ahead of time
you want it to be able to be variable
this allows it to be really clean code
but still full flexibility there so
there's some new enhancements with
strings as well in es6 specifically
template literals so we've all seen this
you know you go ahead and you close off
your quote dollar sign variable dollar
or I'm sorry not dollar sign addition
sign and then start your quotes again
and yeah that that works but it's yeah
am I the only one that's ever forgotten
a single quote or something like that
and realized oh man it's not going to
work okay well now we have template
literals and what we're using here
that's a backtick it is not a quote as a
backtick and within anything that's back
ticked you can do a dollar sign curly
bracket and then any expression it
doesn't have to be just variables here
you could literally use any expression
in JavaScript so as an example you can
evaluate any expression we have a price
attacks and then our total is equal to a
string that says the total price is and
then we're actually evaluating this in
our string and it's going to evaluate
that on the fly and tell us that our
price is this now obviously you'd want
to shorten that down to two digits this
is a example and it also allows you to
really create very easily create
multiline shrink so normally if we
wanted to flow like text across two
lines let's throw a slash in in there
and that's fun right
but with es6 you literally just put a
new line in there and you're done you
don't have to think of anything else it
maintains your multi lines perfectly
with no problem so we also have new new
functions with which strings so we can
check if something starts with and we
can also check if it starts with based
on an index so here we're saying if does
this string start with deeply starting
at index 17 index 17 deeply yes it does
there's also ends with exactly the same
so ends with if we if we don't pass
anything other than the string it's just
looking for that the last bit there if
you pass in with a with an index it's
going to it's going to start starting
from the right it's going to go back 16
and then that's where it ends we also
have includes and we can just ask does
this string include JavaScript but one
thing to keep in mind is that this is
case sensitive so our string contains a
capital S and JavaScript but this
doesn't so if we're looking for this
it's it's going to tell us that it's
false because javascript with the
lowercase s does not exist in there and
we also have repeat and you can just
string repeat if you do like 2.5 it's
going to convert that to an int if you
try to do a negative number it's going
to tell you that's a range error and
actually fail there and the next topic
is enhanced object literals so let's say
we have some variables here first last
an age and we want to assign those
variables to properties of an object so
we create an object person and we say
first is first classes last ages age
this gets repetitive especially if you
have a really big object with a number
of properties let's shorten that BAM we
got first last age you don't even
need the keys but let's say he wanted to
to rename that you you could actually
this part should not say the example
here I was trying to explain was that
this could be like this and you could
have two that actually are named keys
and one that is an object literal there
so I'll fix that slide sorry about that
and you also you can use a shorter
syntax for method definitions on object
initializers so this is an object and we
would normally start our functions here
do a comma new functions but now we
don't even need that function keyword we
literally just get rid of the these the
colon as well as the function word and
now we can just start it off with
parenthesis and then our curly brackets
and it's really just nice shorter syntax
that just makes it cleaner to work with
cleaner to read day in a day in day out
we can also Devine keys that evaluate on
runtime inside of object literals so we
can create an object and actually in our
key for that object for it for each
property we're evaluating at runtime and
as you can see it's going to give us foo
1 is equal to 1 and then as it increases
it food to but again this is that's kind
of yeah I'll clean that up a little bit
there are some es6 syntax in there
looking a little better there's also
some new array features so we have a
rate from let's say we have a variable
called headers and it's equal to query
selector for all h1s in our application
and we're gonna go ahead and get the
titles by mapping all those headers and
just getting the text content now as you
can see we're using arrow function here
single argument so we don't even have to
have the quotes around it and we're
using the implicit return here for the
text content and that's going to give us
a list of all of our each one's text
contents but wait a minute header
stopped map is not a function and why is
that
cuz as I said earlier document query
selector all that's gonna return node
list which again is array like but it is
not an array it's it has some of the
properties of an array but the prototype
will inheritance is not the same there's
a ton of functions such as map that is
not going to be on there MapReduce
filter a ton of them but now we can go
ahead and we can do it with the spread
operator as I as I showed earlier but
that's that's nice but it's not the
easiest to read so the new feature is a
reef from and that just really takes
something that is an iterable that is
not an actual array but it is array like
and turns it into an actual array
it gives it all the same properties of
an array and you're not actually mucking
up the the prototype it's actually
totally clean there you're just
transforming it into an array and now
you have headers array and loop through
that as you need to
oh yeah so let's clean that up a little
bit we can actually just put this all in
one line so instead of having to do our
map on a second line we can actually put
in as the second parameter of a ray from
is a map so we have our callback here h1
and then going in passing back the text
content cleans it up a little bit but
can we do more yes we can so we just go
ahead and throw it all into one single
thing but we could even make this
shorter implicit returns did I even do
it looks like I have an extra slide here
yes
which one right here one more
it will not it does not retain a
reference it is just yeah yeah it's
essentially creating an array from this
array like object but it's really just
it's allowing you to access those values
and really want to get titles it all
it's going to be is an array of the all
the content of those age ones yeah
exactly not a reference absolutely and
so here's a very simple breaks it down a
lot this could be brought even smaller
by bringing this document query selector
all instead of headers here the next
feature is a rate of so array of is very
simple it essentially just takes and
values and creates an array of these
values it would be the same as we could
take array of and just change that to
just a square bracket and a square
bracket and it would literally be the
same array another new feature of arrays
is find so we have our variable posts
and let's say this is a very simplified
version because there's not a whole lot
of room on the screen so we have an ID
and we have a title and let's say we
want to somehow get this object out of
this array so we can't do post not to
because there's no key here for our
array we can't can't do that because
again there's no key what we can do is
we can do post off fine and what find is
gonna do is it takes in a a function
that can go ahead and you return true or
false based on whether or not the the
one that you're evaluating is the one
that you're looking for so it's going to
loop over every single post and give us
post and then with that we're gonna
check the ID and see if it's equal to
two and that's fine
that to our post variable there and that
gives us learn JavaScript deeply filter
you're actually correct me if I'm wrong
you would be modifying the array here
we're not modifying the array of posts
we're specifically finding that whereas
filter it's actually going to take your
array and you're gonna say okay posts is
now equal to whatever this comes back at
so if it comes back as number two now
you're only gonna have a reference to
the second one and not the entire array
itself and it also has find index which
all we changed here was literally change
fine to find index
whoops sorry and we're still doing the
exact same thing and that's going to
tell us console blog post it's at the
first index because as we know arrays
are zero based indexed the next topic is
promises oh this is this one is a little
hard because I will say this is the
longest one of my examples so I needed
to create the code space to be huge and
it looks like it's getting cut off a
little bit over here so just bear with
me so we we have a post promise and
we're just fetching fetch is it's very
similar to dollar sign getting JSON
dollar sign Ajax but it's built in into
the browser itself you don't have to
have any type of library for this at all
it's already built in so we're gonna
fetch the JSON API of work camp Miami
and we're gonna console.log that and
what's that going to give us we're
expecting all the posts but it's gonna
know this is a promise and it's still
pending and now value is still undefined
so what do we need to do with that let's
bring it back to just the call here and
we're gonna add on posts promise dot
then so essentially then is almost like
a callback on a click method or
something like that you you essentially
say ok once this completes this fetch
we want to then do this and it's gonna
take in the data and we're gonna just
console.log the data and what does that
give us like this is a response object
so this is we're on the right track but
we're not there just yet so it tells us
to type URL redirection status
there's header in there there's the body
in there but it's not really discernible
yet it doesn't we don't JavaScript if
your application doesn't know what type
of data you're really trying to get back
yet it just has this data so we're going
to tell it okay run the dot JSON method
on that response body and that is
specific to the response object in
JavaScript and and we're gonna actually
chain it then on to that as well because
what this is going to return us is
another promise so then we're gonna do
another one and pass in data which is
going to be the data that's coming back
from this data JSON and we're gonna
console.log that finally and now we
actually get our posts obviously there's
a lot more data to a post but this is
for example purposes there's not much
room on the screen we can clean that up
a little bit by dropping each of our
then on to another line and that's
exactly the same as it was before it
really just makes it cleaner and easier
to read and but if we were to actually
just change this to say we took out the
a in camp and now we're getting four
fours because that URL doesn't exist
it's gonna give us an error and it
doesn't know how to actually catch that
error so what we need to add is a dot
catch after all of our dot bends we add
a dot catch and that's going to catch an
error and we're just going to do a
console dot error on that error so if we
change this to 2019 they're not planning
for 2019 yet we're still having this one
filled the fetch okay that makes sense
and since we have the catch it's
actually going to catch it if we didn't
have this it would say that it's an
uncaught error in the promise so let's
take a look at building our own promises
so a promise is just an object that
takes in a resolve or it it has a
resolved in a reject method and all your
inside this promise you're gonna do all
your logic everything you want to do and
then eventually you will either resolve
your promise and pass the data back or
you will reject your promise so this is
very simple you can just just all
resolved immediately and it will resolve
immediately if you reject it immediately
it will reject it immediately what that
means is back here if we reject that's
also where it's going to come to the
catch then only happens if it does a
resolve so then only runs if it hits
resolve catch only runs if it hits
reject so let's say we resolve it with
just a string here and we're doing p dot
then you can't see the PP dot then data
console.log data so that's actually
going to give us our value back there if
we reject with an error object here and
we're not catching anything we're just
using the then it's gonna say uncaught
in promise error uh so then we add our
dot catch please remember that there is
a P here you can't see it because the
screen and we are catching our error and
console error in that and now you're not
getting that uncaught and promise it is
catching the error and it's not going to
stop your execution next topic is
classes so here we have an animal class
there's two different ways to declare
classes you can do class declaration or
class expression class declaration is
literally just class animal and then
curly brackets curly bracket a class
expression is you're saying const animal
equals nuke like class and then curly
brackets just a little different syntax
no difference there and what it does
it's just kind of up to you on how you
want to do that so let's say we have a
class called animal and we're gonna add
a constructor here that takes in a name
and we're gonna set that to this dot
name equals the name that's being passed
in and we're gonna have a method on here
called speak and speak is just going to
console
this name makes a noise because we don't
know what type of animal this is just
makes a noise right now let's say we
have a dog that extends animal now I'll
tell you this really came in handy when
I used to be a web developer out of that
tech office so we have a dog that
extends animal and and our speak method
here we're in a console log this name
barks because that's what dogs do so now
we create a puppy it's called spot and
spot barks and as you can see we don't
have a constructor here because it's
gonna inherit the constructor of our
parent class but let's say what if what
if we wanted to have another country
another option there our constructor
what if the dog actually accepted a name
and the breed does this work no this is
gonna fail because we're running the
constructor but we're not calling the
parent constructor at all so you got to
make sure that you call the super and
pass in the same arguments that it's
expecting for the parent class there and
now we could even check dog we could say
okay what what type of breed is a spot
and we'll be able to see the breed but
if an animal was instantiated they
wouldn't have a breed because they're
just an animal and the next topic is a
sink and a weight and this is actually
the last topic of the talk so a sink in
a way to allow us to when Java scripts
running and you run a function and
directly after that function you're
having it do something else it doesn't
stop and finish this first one before it
goes on to the next one it's just gonna
keep chomping through as it goes so if
you actually wanted to wait for some for
some data or anything like that you have
to explicitly do that so here we have a
function called resolve after time I
wish there was a way to scoot that over
some so essentially all it is is it
taking in a variable time and we're
returning a new promise and we're gonna
resolve it with set timeout according to
the time that's passed in
and that's where we're gonna resolve it
resolved after time milliseconds now if
we do a console log start resolve after
and then we do a result equals resolve
after 500 milliseconds and then we do a
console log of our result there and then
we console log ending resolve after what
we're gonna get is we're gonna get
starting solve after or starting resolve
after and the promise is pending it
that's what the result is there and then
we're gonna get ending resolve after
that's not what we want we want we want
our value to come back here so what do
we do well we can add a sync and we can
add a wait here and what that does is
it's telling our function here this is
an asynchronous function and when we're
calling that asynchronous function we're
gonna await for the value so before it
goes on to the next line before it
console logs that result we want it to
await when resolved after finishes and
then assign and then console.log it but
wait wait is only valid in inside an
instinctive Aled in an async function
it's not valid at the top-level scope as
you see this is not and it's probably
easier to see if you can see the whole
screen but this is not within its own
function here this is just top level
code with nothing above it and then
there's just one function here so what
we would have to do is we would have to
wrap this this is async function async
call and this function is the awaited
function or is the just the regular
function so this is our async function
we're gonna start the asynchronous call
then we're gonna await our resolve after
get the result and as you can see start
async all resolved after 500
milliseconds you can even see the
difference in the time there the 500
milliseconds that have passed and then
ending async call afterwards so it's not
hitting this one before the value
actually comes back to us we have the
value back to us now before we actually
move on from this line we already have
the value and you can await as many
function calls as you want to I can
await resolve after 500 a wait resolve
after 5,000 so as you can see it
is waiting five five seconds there it's
waiting a half a second there and it's
it's resolving in the correct order here
so while this talk has been long there's
a number of things that we have not
covered here today there's things in es6
that we have not even touched on
generators symbols proxies sets and week
sets maps and week maps and even more
that's still in review by the tc39 right
now and honestly it is impossible to
include everything that that's in here
because of the fact that it is
ever-changing javascript is going to be
continuing to change for years to come
and we need to make sure that we stay
up-to-date as well as we can
most of these functions here or most of
these features here that we have not
gone over
I will admit are features that I have
barely touched myself so I find that
every feature that I did discuss is the
bulk of what you're going to need out of
es6 in order to learn the the later
things today and and just continue on
with your javascript knowledge now what
I would recommend if you are interested
in learning more about es6 I would
recommend west bosses es6 for everyone
course unfortunately his he just had a
sale that ended where it was like 40 50
dollars off of the normal price but this
course right here is incredible this is
the course that I took in order to get
caught up today on es6 and it is pretty
much the only course I took on es6
because it is it's incredible it's it's
an amazingly well done course with a ton
of examples a ton of real-world code
examples that are not the foo bar Baz
stuff that some of the slides I have had
been yeah continue on with that he also
has a react for beginners course as well
as a number of other courses and I would
highly recommend that thank you for your
time